We have a voicemail number, which
is two one nine two David P..
Here's a caller who doesn't like Trump but
doesn't really like Biden and is thinking
of voting third party. Let's take a listen.
Hi. I was just watching your last video about how
out of control Donald Trump is. And I agree with
you. I do not want this man re elected. Right. But
I would not like Biden and others either, because
the lesser of two evils is still evil. Have
you looked into Joe Jorgensen, the libertarian
candidate? And if not, you should and I would love
to actually get a call and be on your platform
to speak my opinion as to why I'm voting
Libertarian. And maybe you could give a
libertarian a chance to give us vitalized and
they will not allow her on the debate stage.
OK, so listen, I don't know what state you're
voting in, but you need to I really clearly
identify who do you want less Trump or Biden.
If you want Trump less than you want Biden
voting third party again, depending on where you
live, is de facto helping Donald Trump. So, no,
I'm not going to be voting third party this year.
I'm with Noam Chomsky. I am with Bernie Sanders
on the importance of removing Donald Trump. This
idea of the lesser of two evils is still evil.
You know, it's like at a certain point we
have to stop assigning these words to it.
If you take a scale, let me even do this right
now. If you take a scale that goes from good to
evil. OK. You've got good at the top and you've
got evil at the bottom. It doesn't really matter
where it goes from being good to evil, like you
could say. Well, it goes from good to evil here
or it goes from good to evil here. All that
matters is if you put Trump closer to evil than
you put Biden. Doesn't matter how you characterize
it. Then you've got to vote for Biden. That said,
it's really that simple. And I think that Noam
Chomsky, in the clips we played earlier this week,
did a fantastic job of distilling this down
to its most fundamental basic components.
Review that clip if you're interested. But no, I
will be voting for Biden. I believe we all should.
And then we actually have a chance at being
activists for policies that make sense. Under
Trump. We have no chance. And that's what we've
seen over the last four years. On the bonus show
today, we will talk about more news related to
the post office. I won't even tell you what it
is. We'll talk about it. We will also talk about
some studies now that are connecting blood type
and corona virus infection risk, which are very
interesting. We'll also talk about South Carolina,
Medicaid and Planned Parenthood. All of
those stories and more and more is important
on today's bonus show. Also join me tonight at
seven thirty p.m. Eastern for the Trump Town Hall,
followed by the Joe Biden Town Hall in lieu
of the second debate, which has been canceled.
That is tonight on YouTube, Twitch
and Facebook. I will see you then.